[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and today we have
a special episode for you it's the end
of the year it's the end of 2017 and so
we're gonna do is we're gonna compile a
bunch of our favorite answers to many of
our favorite questions from many of our
favorite episodes throughout the year
now this isn't a comprehensive list of
all of our favorite episodes but we
think we have some good answers to some
good questions throughout this episode
we wanted to give that to you as a
year-end gift so you can start your new
year off right speaking of the new year
the minimalists are going to be doing
something different in 2018 with our
social media and we're gonna be writing
about that over at the blog over the
minimalists com if you head over there
you sign up for our email newsletter
you'll be the first to receive new
essays and podcast show notes and
minimalism news and all of our tour
dates but I'm also gonna write an essay
about how we're going to use social
media more intentionally in 2018 in fact
we're gonna be taking a month-long break
from social media in January 2018 and
then hopping back on in a much different
way and we'll explain that on future
podcasts we can have some discussions
about that but the essays we're actually
gonna do two essays
one's gonna talk about why we're taking
the break and then the other one is
going to talk about how we are using
social media differently and maybe you
can find a few ingredients from our
recipe that you can apply to use social
media more intentionally in 2018
yourself alright let's open to this
episode we are headed to a few places
early 2018 we're going to be in Las
Vegas
January 14th the House of Blues and
that's a charity event to help out the
loss of Vegas Victims Fund after that
terrible tragedy that happened earlier
this year we're trying to help out we
can't change the world together but we
can at least help out to the best of
and then in March 2018 we're headed to
Australia and New Zealand you can find
tickets to all of our live events over
at les is now calm it's the lessons now
tour we give an in-depth talk about
minimalism we record a live version of
the podcast we answer a bunch of your
questions along the way
alright let's dive into this best of
episode the first clip you're gonna hear
is from podcast episode number 52 this
episode was called stress I am a teacher
and I used to pay third grade last year
and I made the big transition to being
great this year as a literacy teacher
currently I have about 120 students and
there are many times probably about
twice a week or every other week I have
to grade 120 papers and each paper is
about four to five pages and I can't do
that during my work day and you know I
don't know if I can go another year it
was very stressful for me I didn't find
it in enjoying I am currently on the
lookout for another job and if I don't
get another job then I will have to go
another year with reading that many
papers and that one is my weekend with
you know after school so I really lost a
lot of time and I'm wondering if you
guys think that it's worth it to stick
with this job I am hoping to get a
younger grade I really enjoy that I find
that that is my forte but if I don't I'm
going to have to damage it so I get this
kind of a two-part question do you think
that that is a job that I should stay
with or and like if I can stay with it
how can I manage it back Wow Tasha that
is Josh now were talking about this as
we were listening to the question I said
man Josh it's like she has to read a
novel a week uh-huh and then you were
like it's a really crappy novel though
right right because it's a bunch of
fourth graders which you know I'm sure
some of the papers are endearing but
yeah
creators or eighth graders so yeah she
wants to go like down to like four
thirds before right yeah so Tasha um you
know the first question that stands out
is is it worth it to hang on to this job
I need to know a little bit more
information to answer that but I guess
here's what I'll say yes and no um yes
it is absolutely worth it if this is the
only way you have to pay your bills
right now like if you're gonna go
bankrupt you know by not having it so
you know what is the average American
how how many months away
how many paychecks away are they from
bankruptcy - okay so I hope you're not
you know fall into that average yeah
but if this is the only job you have and
yes if you don't have a job for four
months you're gonna go bankrupt then yes
it absolutely is worth it to hang on
right now if you are in a position to
where you can find a lower grade to go
to and you could do something that
aligns more with your values and beliefs
than no it is absolutely not worth
hanging on to this job I really hope
that you get that job that you just went
out for but but yeah at the end of the
day pay your bills make sure that those
are that you got food on your table
essentially and then I was gonna say to
you know there's no harm with all the
paperwork and stuff that you have I
don't think there's any harm to go to
someone a superior your boss or you know
someone else who has Authority and and
tell them like hey look this is an
unbelievable amount of work that I have
to do each week and it's not reasonable
I need to either have less students or I
need to have you know someone to help
assist me or maybe if somehow we could
squeeze in you know a few hours a week
somewhere during work hours for me to
get these papers them but I don't think
that's an unreasonable ask I know when I
was managing a lot of people I respect
the people who came to me and they're
like hitting my job's too hard and
here's why and sometimes I would look at
them and be like I'm sorry this is your
job
continue to do what you're doing or
maybe they bring up a good point and
and enough people would say something to
me and I'd be like you know what
something does need to be looked at but
I never looked it down on anyone for for
bringing that up
III think that there are certainly those
types of bosses out there if you're
working forward on those bosses I don't
care what they're willing to negotiate
with you then get out of there because I
would never work for someone who would
look down on me for asking something
like right in and so what you're what
she said is you may not have that much
control over the curriculum but what
you're saying is is there a way you
could take back some control of that
curriculum so that your grading fewer
papers or you find a way to do it more
effectively because right now Ryan she
she doesn't find it very meaningful that
she doesn't find this work to be
meaningful at all and there are
basically three reasons what's the name
of that book I'm blanking on if it comes
to me I'll bring about I think it's
called drive I've talked about it before
but there are three there are three
reasons that we that we that we feel
compelled to do work and money is
generally not one of them now granted we
all have to pay the bills so so if you
can earn enough money to get that
discussion off the table ay-ay-ay $5,000
raise it may not be the the deal-breaker
you're not gonna go take a job you
absolutely hate for an extra five
thousand dollars and leave a job that
you love in order to just make a little
bit extra money for whatever reason and
so there are three things one is mastery
one is a meaning so a Purpose Driven
work in some way and and the other the
third point is I'm feeling like Rick
Perry right now not remember just keep
saying um just fill a blank space with
the homes that's what I Department of
Energy yeah so so it is mastery autonomy
and purpose right so right now you
probably have mastery although you're
learning a lot more because you move
from grade three to grade eight so
you're actually growing through that so
that's part of the mastery process
autonomy yeah you're by yourself in
charge of a large group of children
every day so you've got the autonomy but
you don't have the purpose on what
you're doing and you might not ever find
120 papers a week meaningful and that's
okay
everything else feels meaningful but it
doesn't seem to me like it does for you
I can talk to you about a couple
different approaches I was talking to my
partner about this voicemail last night
so she she used to teach at the
University a health class I know some of
her students listen to this because they
will tweet me occasionally but I know
she had to grade papers
well not 120 papers a week but she had
to grade a lot of papers and she found
out what she said why and I don't enjoy
doing this at all how can I find a way
to make this more enjoyable she would do
it in the bathtub so she's like at least
I'm gonna do something that's enjoyable
while I'm doing this and find a way to
make it if not meaningful at least a
little bit more enjoyable while I'm
doing it I can tell you my approach so I
teach that writing class and I have
there's a final assignment at the end of
the four week writing class that people
have to turn in and I have to to grade
all of those but I get some help on
those as well so I have two very
talented writers Sean Halleck helps me
out with with the class overall and then
chase Knight who is a very talented
novelist and they'll both give me their
notes on the papers and so I saw have a
final say and final approval on anything
that I want to to communicate with with
the student but it what it does is it
gives me the opportunity to see someone
else's perspective and I grow in that
process as well so is there a teacher's
assistant or is there some way that you
can get another student to help you with
part of that that is within the bounds
of your authority there at your school
that is genius what like a what a Tim
Ferriss s approach like outsourcing
someone to grade her papers I don't know
if that's like you know illegal or not
you know I don't know what her contract
says sure but yeah that's a possibility
like that's that is definitely plausible
cuz you know I know there is some you
know call it writing college student out
there who would be willing to you know
grade papers for you know 50 bucks or so
you know something that is you know not
not a cheap sum of money but something
that would be reasonable I'm sure that
you know she could fine
yeah and and I'm willing to pay so I
make less money from my writing class
because I get help with this
but I also get another perspective and
it helps me grow as well when I see the
other feedback that other people have it
helps me provide better feedback in the
future as well so that that may help you
grow so you also asked about you know
should I pursue another job yes I think
ultimately you need to pursue a
different job and it sounds to me like
eighth grade is not the perfect fit for
you I think about my former spouse
Carrie she is an eighth grade teacher
and loves teaching eighth grade I
remember one year she was needed to move
up to ninth grade and she did it back
when we were married and she absolutely
hated it just that one year difference
and now obviously kids these days
obviously that one your difference makes
a big difference because of puberty and
all the changes but she loves eighth
grade hated ninth grade and so it may be
Natacha yeah you need to find a way to
get back to if third grade is right for
you or what is right for you you need to
get some clarity on what you want here
and so you need to start asking some
really powerful questions what is my
outcome right and why do I want that
outcome it can't be that you just want
to switch over to third grade because
you're gonna grade fewer papers because
you need to find this meaningful right
it's not you don't want to be running
from one thing you want to be running to
wherever you are going and I think
you're going to experience less stress
along the way if and only if you're
running towards something you want to do
is whether that's third grade fourth
grade fourth grade whatever or
completely different career outside of
teaching get really clear about what you
want your what you want your outcome to
be I think that is the the key to this
whole her whole question man is to come
up with a plan yes to to find the light
at the end of the tunnel and figure out
what what you are running towards
because I know when we're in the
corporate world when we were writing the
minimalists I was going to school and we
were working 6070 sometimes 80 hours a
week it was miserable and we kept that
up for about a year now you know writing
for the minimalist was a bit of an
outlet so you know maybe that was more
entertainment than it was you know work
but there were so meaningful
yeah it was a lot more meaningful but
there were certainly a lot of times
where I was like writing an essay I'm
like gosh I really just want to like sit
and watch TV right now I don't want to
do this so I still had to Drudge to that
drudgery a little bit
but it wasn't it was not a sustainable
workweek for me school work and writing
for the minimalists I knew it was not
sustainable but I did know that if I
could do that for a short enough period
of time you know a year is kind of what
I had committed to I knew that I could
go somewhere else after that year but
that's my whole point is that yes I put
myself into into this unsustainable work
situation temporarily I temporarily
deprived myself which Josh and I talked
a lot about in a lot of different ways
and yeah that's that's kind of the
outlook I would recommend Tasha have it
she has to she has to absolutely be
there for another year
that's okay look at it as a temporary
situation but know what you're gonna do
after that year because you're really
gonna fall into despair like what you're
saying there because you're fall into
despair if you don't feel like there is
that light at the end of the tunnel if
there's no hope in the future then yeah
of course you are going to start to feel
feel some certain amount of discontent
and it's gonna grow and grow and grow
because you yeah you think one day there
will be something will change but if you
don't know what that change is because
you're not clear on that that outcome
then you're gonna feel more growing
despair as things go on it I tend to
think of regret as sort of this judgment
of the past but the stress that you're
experiencing is a verdict on some
non-existent future and the cool thing
is you get to change what what that
future existence actually is and Ryan I
I was looking for an article to
highlight this and I won't read the
whole thing but our friend Leo Bob alte
who's in our documentary he's uh he and
his wife Eva they have six kids and he
wrote this essay called the busy
person's guide to reducing stress and it
goes a little something like this stress
is one of the biggest causes of health
problems in many people's lives it can
cause heart disease depression anxiety
attacks sleep problems autoimmune
diseases weight problems and more but
we're busy how do we drop the stress
levels down while we're still getting
our jobs done taking care of ourselves
and our families the busy person might
have no time for week-long meditation
retreats
vacations or weekly counseling sessions
so what can be done I'm gonna be brief
about this there are five small things
that you can do a few shifts and mindset
a couple actions that take only a couple
minutes these won't solve the most
severe stress problems but they will
help most of us number one be completely
in one task instead of being in the
stressful task switching mode take your
next task but everything else go and
just be in the moment with this one task
so that may contradict what I was
talking about being in the bathtub with
with the paperwork but I think maybe
being in the bathtub with the paperwork
could be the best way to actually be in
the moment there as well so so don't put
it off don't postpone it just sit there
with that task and what he says here
really resonated with me Ryan he said
there will always be a next task the
nature of tasks and lists is that they
are never-ending so let those other
tasks come later
just be in this one task let let it be
your entire universe number two he says
see your ideals and let go of control I
love this first line here fear is
causing you to be stressed not external
factors like your job or family or
family problems so fear is is it's your
internal fear it's not all these
external things it's not actually the
paperwork that's causing her to be
stressed it's the the way she
experiences that that paperwork right
you in fact when you you talk to high
functioning executives and companies
you'll hear two words that come up a lot
I'm very busy or I'm stressed mm-hmm if
something's wrong I'm just really
stressed right now
and the truth is if you follow that that
that's stress far enough you're really
finding someone's fear that's what
they're afraid of
your stress leads to your fear and so
you've got to find a way to be able to
let that go and realize that it's not
those external factors that you're
afraid of that fear is internal and it
always will be
number three he says accept people and
smile
we get upset at other people because
they don't meet our ideals of how they
should act instead try accepting them
for who they are and recognize that like
you they're imperfect and seeking
happiness and struggling with finding
that happiness they're doing their best
accept them smile and enjoy your time
with this person I think it'd be really
good advice for Steve the last question
how I deal with non minimalist well
accept and smile mm-hmm
number four this is what I do a lot take
a brief walk when things are getting
stressful take two to three minutes and
take a walk and clear your mind the
short walk does wonders I agree or a
long walk I will often go on a long walk
to clear my mind in fact when it's cold
in the winter I there's a gym that I go
to and I just walk the track over and
over and over and until I'm feeling less
stress and I make sure I'm breathing
accordingly and number five do short
mindfulness practices you don't you
don't have to meditate for 30 minutes to
get the benefits of mindfulness you can
do a quick body scan see how your body
is feeling right now in ten seconds so
those are our five tips we'll put a link
to that entire article in in the show
notes I think that'll help out and then
last Ryan Xie Tasha asked is this worth
it it's sticking it out worth it and
I'll just repeat what Ryan said here no
but make a plan before you decide to go
are you in debt then get out of debt you
can see our are get out of debt plan at
the minimalists comm slash freedom I
think that will help you out a lot also
create some sort of deadline Ryan talked
about a one-year deadline mine was two
years to get out of debt figure out what
your deadline is and no matter what
stick to that deadline to make that
change in your life and then ultimately
figure out what your outcome is get so
clear about what that outcome is because
making this transition is going to be
difficult but it can lead to a simpler
less stressed life all right the next
clip you're gonna hear is from podcast
episode number 56 this episode was
called clothing and from what I remember
was one of the longer episodes and we
really don't
- wardrobe and clothing so you can go
back and check any of these in our
archives any of the clips today or any
other past episodes over at the
minimalists com
slash podcast my question is in regards
to purchasing items of high quality I
know a lot is talked in the podcast and
I'm talking mentoring in New York about
purchasing quality things and I'm
referring from this question
specifically to clothing I remember in
the documentary there was questions for
the discussion of fast fashion and I was
wondering if you had any suggestions for
brands or stores to buy clothes at that
laughs so yeah we can talk about brands
for sure but with another caveat
so a already mentioned you probably
don't need any more clothes but the
second thing is the things that work for
me may not necessarily work for you the
things that add value to my life may not
add value to yours and there's a whole
bunch of different reasons one is we're
all shaped differently I'm 6 foot 2 160
pounds and so the things that fit me
probably won't fit you if you're of a
different size sometimes they might so
but keep that in mind same thing with
Ryan these things may not fit we can
talk about brands that we think are
ethical though we could Ryan we could
probably start by talking about what
we're wearing right now and then that's
gonna be typically what we what we do
wear and then you know how do we how do
we assess you know what what to wear
right so I'm looking first yeah I'm well
yeah I'll look at you and you're wearing
a black t-shirt yes I think you're
wearing pants I can't tell from under
the table but yes I assume you're
wearing the blue jeans I usually see you
wearing and then you're probably because
there's snow on the ground outside the
window you're probably not wearing your
zero shoes no you're wearing boots I'm
assuming you know and if there's a
normal boots you wear they have these
bright orange laces in them yes so up
real nice that's yeah that's your pop of
color and then you have some miss
matching socks I'm guessing probably yes
I forget yeah and and so that is sort of
your uniform in a way right yeah
definitely I mean yeah I don't think you
would identify I'm putting on my uniform
no just the clothes you wear everyday
you want to talk about why why you've
decided to have that sort of type of
uniform that's wearing a very same or
very similar thing every day
yeah it's easy it's simple it's a pretty
simple answer no I wear the same thing
every day because we'll a like it you
know we but most of us have seen the
articles on how if you have a uniform
you have less choices to make throughout
the day which is important right because
you have only so much brain power right
that you can use to discern between
different choices so you know not the
like you know make those choices when I
get up I know exactly what I'm gonna
wear
it's something like 120 choices
difficult choices a day and surprisingly
picking your wardrobe is takes up
several of those choices yeah yeah
definitely yeah I mean if yeah
especially if you're putting clothes on
taking clothes off pretty clothes back
on yeah there are several choices that
you are you're forsaking and it's not
like you can't make choices after 120
choices it's you don't have the mental
capacity to sit there and be deliberate
with your choices
uh-huh yeah always said you have 120
deliberate choices that you can make
during the day is about what the study
shows yeah so so yeah I mean I got an
American Apparel shirt although I guess
they just went on a business yeah they
they filed banker for bankruptcy so so
you can't get American well yeah I'm
sure you can still get it it's weird
they've had the strange business model
right they well their founder Dov
Charney who was sort of this clothing
pioneer and a bit of a genius yeah it
seemed in the clothing world because
he's the first person that pioneered
like really soft shirts that were better
fitting and higher quality threads and
made in America but then it also turns
out that he was allegedly a kind of a
terrible person right if you go and read
the the news reports he was gonna
trouble for some like sexual harassment
stuff for something right he was a jerk
to his employees and yet in the sexual
harass yeah and I certainly would not
recommend well I don't know so when I
started wearing American Apparel
t-shirts on a regular basis I usually
have to get like seven because I'll go
through like seven shirts a year so I'll
have like a week's worth of shirts or
wear those for 52 weeks you know during
that time they get holes in them they
get super faded which I guess is cool
now
but uh but you know when I started
wearing them four or five years ago the
quality was not that good like it for
every four shirts I bought I would have
to like return or exchange one because
of some kind of defect in the shirt
right so I'm not like sitting here
getting behind American Apparel they fit
me the best and that's why I like them
right and and this was by the way out of
all the t-shirts that ride like they fit
me by far the best so that the founder
Dov Charney he was forced out of the
company because of those sexual
allegations right and so and the weird
thing is when he was forced out I think
that's when the the quality started to
diminish and recently it sounds like
they their quality has improved now I
don't know if they'll transition into
some sort of wholesale business or
you'll still be able to order online and
they'll just close all their their
retail shops that might be a possibility
yeah not really sure where they go from
here if not I can I can recommend some
different brands that have worked for me
but may work for you I've been meaning
to try the smart wool t-shirts like the
next time I need to buy t-shirts I'm
going to get at least one smart rule
t-shirt because I hear that like a they
dry really quickly they're very
comfortable and the biggest problem I
have with my t-shirts which is why I
really ruined them which I don't think
this is cool with the cool kids is like
I because I wear these to the gym as
well
uh-huh and then like they just start to
oh they just get a little odor to them
uh-huh even after I like wash them and
stuff like it it just starts to like get
embedded into the fibers yeah well smart
wools great man my smart little doesn't
do that yeah so that's yeah that's what
I'm gonna try that out when I the next
somebody new t-shirt but right now I
mean these are these are still pretty
good yeah the seven that I have and then
my jeans barbell jeans I've had these
for a month and a half first pair of
barbell jeans I've ever owned they're
the most comfortable jeans I've ever had
I can't really speak to the durability
but I can certainly speak to how
comfortable they are I was doing karate
a couple podcasts ago and my jeans
actually someone have you up on Twitter
yesterday they're like hey what's up
pair of jeans you recommended a few
podcasts ago but yeah barbell jeans are
great I used to wear j.crew jeans and
they were they were good like they were
durable but you know I'm just I got like
you know just I'm a bigger guy so you
know having
having jeans that fit me it's it's great
but I can't well I can't do karate and
j.crew jeans right but they were they
were great jeans I really really liked
them and they're like pretty expensive
actually barbell are pretty expensive
too you know unless you get them on sale
or something which I would do sometimes
I certainly didn't go out of my way to
get them on sale or I didn't just buy
jeans when they came on sale right all
right sometimes I would get lucky and I
like go buy a pair of jeans I'm like oh
sweet like these are you know half off
right now but uh yeah the problem is I
will often see oh oh man it's 50% off I
should go ahead and buy this thing I
know it's a hundred percent off if you
don't buy it walk away from the store
and save a hundred percent of your money
unless you absolutely need the thing
yeah and then my boots I don't even know
what brand these are I know that they
are they're comfortable uh-huh I keep my
feet warm they are waterproof they they
look pretty good this I need to replace
the soles on oh because the soleus have
like no tread on them I've fallen like
four to six times in my parking lot I
was carrying snowboards the other day
and like totally ate it but yeah cuz my
my tread on the bottom is like pretty
pretty worn out but yeah talk about the
board room I think it's a really great
thing you talk about I'm not gonna throw
these boots out I'm going to have them
resoled and there are times where if you
have a huge rip on the top of a boot
you're going to get rid of it right
right you want water coming in or
whatever you know your toes pokey now
but I caught all our timberland boots
those are the main boots that I wear and
I have them resold quite frequently
until they find the leather itself
finally just wears out yeah
so having having boots resold a local
your shoes resoled if if they if the
type of shoes you can have resold is a
very responsible way of keeping those
shoes around for a long time now you can
wear the same pair of boots for many
many years every single day if you if
you're willing to take good care of them
and
them have them resoled I am so yeah I'm
we're in some timberland boots right now
I'm wearing smart wool socks they keep
my feet from stinking in in the winter I
don't necessarily wear them in the
summer all I've never tried I've had
people tell me like yeah wearing nice
wool and the summer will help actually
keep you cooler so might be something
that all that I'll try out for sure the
pair of pants I'm wearing right now are
from Mission Workshop they're based out
of San Francisco like that company Ola
they make some awesome bags yeah you you
had their bag for a long time in fact
Mariah's using I think mariah is using
your workshop bag yeah I've got the
Menaul bag now
but yeah she yeah I gave her the mission
like I actually got those mandalas off
of you so I could give her my mission
workshop back oh nice because you you
traveled all around Europe for about a
month and and had those bags with you
and the only thing you carried by the
way for people who are listening if you
want links to all the stuff we're
talking about you can just go to the
show notes at the minimalists comm slash
podcast or if you sign up for our email
newsletter we send out all the notes to
everyone whenever a new episode comes
out so you won't miss any of the show
notes so anything we're talking about
today I'm not gonna start riling off a
bunch of websites you'll go to find it
in the show notes yeah mission workshop
or the pants that I'm wearing and they
fit me really well I'm imagining I've
really really really thin legs these
pants will not fit you very warmly not
because you're a big manly man with your
a with your big calves and but these are
the they make different pants but
they're really high quality I can I
exercise in these I could do yoga and
these if I wanted to do karate in them I
could do I don't I wouldn't call what
you do karate right whatever I would
call it like interpretive karate well
can you do interpretive karate I could
sweet I don't know if I should though so
yeah these pants work really well they
have a great cell phone pocket on the
side which keeps my phone and the
emissions away from my private parts
which is really good I also keeps me
from sitting on it and I tend to keep my
phone in airplane mode anyway but if not
it's there I'm not in my side pocket the
zips up and they're just really
comfortable man I wear them every single
day there
black they have a couple different
colors I think the one I'm calling
wearing is called the signal pants I
also own a one other pair of pants the
division pants also from Mission
Workshop the sweater I'm wearing today
are actually underneath the sweater this
is a used t-shirt from save khaki one of
my my favorite t-shirt brands I got it
used on eBay though and so that's one of
the things I like to do if I need
something I'll see if I can first get it
used cuz I think it's one of the most
responsible ways to to purchase gently
used clothes it's still new to me the
the cardigan I'm wearing is from ever
Lane and I really like what ever Lane
does ever Lane has this transparency
policy or transparent pricing they'll
tell you exactly how much it cost for
them to manufacture the thing I'll show
you all the costs to go in the
manufacturing and so say this sweater
costs I know ninety dollars or something
and I've worn this sweater for years
they'll show you the 50 it costs them
fifty dollars and then their what their
profit margin is on on top of that and
so it's trans radically transparent
pricing some other shirts riding that
you might want to try if you're not able
to get the shirt so you're wearing
anymore
Michael stars they're made in the United
States and they're really super
comfortable is where I'm one of his or
their t-shirts yesterday Michael stars
is has been a good brand for me so safe
khaki Michael stars are the t-shirts I I
personally enjoy using but I've never
got anything uh Pat ever Lane is it is
ever lean a brand or is it a supplier
it's a brand okay yeah and they make
really good t-shirts as well so the
folks at our at our coffee house band at
Coffee Co Joshua Weaver and his wife
Sarah they've actually done some photo
work for them in the past but they know
that they do really beautiful minimalist
clothing and and source it in an ethical
way I don't think they make everything
that they make in the United States but
that's okay they still find ways to make
it ethically outside of our outside of
our borders the coat that I wore here
today is from Patagonia and I'm I won't
beat you over the head with their with
their story but I
really encouraged to go check it out
Yvonne who the guy who started the
company he is just amazing and his
ethics for his company are beautiful he
wants to make really great items that
last a lifetime
in fact they sent a van around the
country and repair your stuff for you so
my patagonia coat rips in time or
something wears out they will repair
something on it for me even if I've
owned it for 20 years and they also
encourage people to not buy their stuff
I love it firstly new things they're
advertisement you do not need this
jacket right right I mean though what
they'll say is buy our stuff used if you
have the opportunity to buy it used get
your stuff fixed instead of buying
something new and when you actually do
need something new then we are here for
you also on Black Friday they did
something really cool Ryan they donated
a hundred percent of their profits it
was awesome
it's really cool all the money they made
on on Black Friday they donated that to
charity
ever Lane in the past has closed on
Black Friday so we just mentioned
Everleigh in a moment ago they'll close
their website you go there on Black
Friday or maybe the cyber monday or
maybe even both and it says sorry our
website is closed our REI which is the
the retailer that sells a lot of
Patagonia stuff they they closed on
Black Friday they have this whole opt
outside campaign instead of just opting
out of Black Friday it's hey get outside
while you can it's Black Friday everyone
else is shopping why don't you spend
some time doing something more
intentional with your day so I just
really enjoy when different companies do
do different things like that that are
contributing to the greater good in the
summer
speaking of contributing to the greater
good and the summer I tend to wear Tom's
TOMS shoes they work really well for me
they're my favorite walking shoes
actually I know you wear zero shoes yeah
my feet stinks so bad when I wear it
sometimes maybe he's like smart wool
socks in the song man no yeah we're this
year issues cuz my my feet can sweat
freely without ruining a pair of Tom's
yeah so if the folks who saw the
documentary they often thought you were
barefoot yeah or they'll see us on tour
and you're wearing these zero shoes
which is like dude come on man
barefoot really I'm like I got shoes on
it's not very big they're just they're
minimal minimal exactly yeah but you've
never really enjoyed those man I love
them except for the first two weeks of
the summer that I wear them because
because like you you got to break your
feet in man uh-huh because like you sure
you do it start using muscles that
you're not used to using with padded
shoes you've got calluses you got a you
know put on your feet because it's
really like walking barefoot but it's a
little bit of protection yeah so during
this summer like Marv and I will easily
get like 10 to 15,000 steps in a day
easy I will not like those first two
weeks I won't do 10,000 steps in those
shoes like I wear sneakers or something
around but like I can't do 10,000 steps
today two weeks straight because like it
takes it takes some time to wear your
feet in but what but once they get worn
in like there they are the most
comfortable shoes I've ever worn my life
once it once your feet get worn in not
the shoes yeah so what I like about
everything that you wear is nothing that
you're wearing right now has any any
logo on it and when I wear Tom's in in
the summer I'm not wearing them and the
winter here just because you don't want
to get those what but because it's just
thin canvas basically they're very
similar what does that call zero step so
it is with it yeah so just like the the
zero shoes but they're they're zero step
where the the heel to toe ratio is the
same and what I like about those are
very comfortable I walk a ton and then
what I don't like about them is they
have a gigantic logo on the back and I
prefer not to wear logos on on any of my
stuff because I don't want to be a
walking billboard in fact I don't want
to pay people to advertise for them that
seems a little absurd to me
there are a few examples so what I do
with those Tom's is I take the logos off
right I just I remove the the just
unstitched the the logo on the back and
on the side and then people often ask
like those kind of look like Tom's what
and and it's an interesting conversation
starter I do like what they do they
donate a lot of their profits they also
donate a lot of shoes and I wear
eyeglasses to third-world countries and
I appreciate that
I know there's been some criticism for
their founder Blake and and and some of
the things they've done in in different
countries but I have not found yet that
criticism is very valid it seems like
people
who who are criticizing may not
necessarily care as much about
contribution as that company does yeah
and so you know what the - I think some
people though we're like the legs are
proud of the Tom's logo yeah because of
the contribution they do sure and though
yeah and they so it's you know I guess
it's just you know personal preference
just depending on part of its aesthetics
yeah absolutely
I like the aesthetic of being somewhat
logo free the only logo I think I have
on anything is my Patagonia coat that I
warranty even take it off though yeah I
think it would it would ruin the front
part otherwise I would take it off but
although I'll tell you man
in Montana it's everyone here seems to
work oh yeah it's like it's like
functional know what it so it's
Patagonia out west and out east it is
what's the other North Face
yeah North Face East yeah my partner
Beck's she just got a new coat this
winter finally after having a Patagonia
Co for probably the last decade or so
and she got she ended up getting in
North Face coat because she she and she
got it from REI and really loves it I
mean really really simple let's see what
else do we what else do we were oh we
just thought we talked briefly about
bags you're wearing them at all or you
you you use them and all that I'm
wearing them at all back right now and
the springs ryan is wearing the 2017
spring bag yes no yeah I bought about
your man all bags off you can talk about
that great for you I love how so so did
you still have the Malcolm fonti a bag
that you still use rice the one that was
rice you did say raise everyone else
listen you this would have ignored it
too but now we're know we're very aware
that you said rice Ryan
carbohydrates go ahead so you've been
trying so hard to find a better bag and
so have thousands of other people
appearing that Malcolm fonti a bag and
every at the wool I mean I've only you
had them in all bag and then I think you
had another one that you returned or
something but uh but yeah it's funny man
because yes that Malcolm Ponzi a bag
like everyone asked
about that and it is a great travel back
for me like I don't like the single
strap that's the only criticism I have
on it and I much prefer it right and I
and I am I am the type of well this is
dis just goes to show our personalities
the mission workshop bag I had was
basically a big duffel bag so I would
like full might think I would duffel bag
backpack
yeah big duffel bag backpack I would
fold my clothes is you know like half
now which really means he stuff I was
definitely closer to the bag but that's
exactly what I wanted was like just you
know something I could cram a bunch of
stuff in sure um where the Malcolm font
a bag is very like OCD yes you've got
pockets and like pouches and everything
to put different things in and it works
really really well and I used it while
we were on the tour 2014 and it was
great I just prefer the backpack I
prefer the duffel bag part of it but the
Menaul was really good for that because
I think you have a little bit more space
and I think it's a little bit more
organized than just like the duffel bag
approach so it's kind of like I think
the Menaul is like a blend between the
mission workshop bag and the Malcolm
font tae bag and it's still a backpack
so it works really really well for me
especially because it comes with that
little second bag that counts as a it's
a carry-on right like your personal item
so I got that big Menaul back from you
that I could put in the overhead and
then I could you know put some clothes
and stuff in this other bag along with
my laptop so forth and so on and if it's
perfectly underneath the seat of an
airplane yes like I never have to check
a bag yeah it's it's your man purse
Moritz members yeah I Shawn are our
stalwart producer he he uses a fanny
pack just like the powerful Joe Rogan
does yeah
I will never make fun of a fanny pack
again now that Joe Rogan I know so if I
need it if any I wouldn't I would I just
don't need it I don't carry much with me
the the wallet that I have is a money
clamp which we talked about on previous
episode and I and I have a phone in my
pocket and I have chapstick in my pocket
and I actually have a bunch of pills in
my pocket too but that's just my like my
vitamins for Louis's suction
we're talking yeah what brands and so
what brand are rice I think was them
yeah yes favorite brands of rice right
no so uh you mentioned my bag the
Malcolm fonti a bag now bag that
everyone asks about now literally over a
thousand people have asked me where did
where did where can I get that bag
that's in your documentary and I don't
my short answer is you can't well first
off we've done a horrible job if you
watched our documentary and the biggest
takeaway was I need to get that back
it's funny you say that right because I
was on so we just put up that love
people use things wallpaper and I posted
a picture of it on our Instagram account
and back-to-back comments on that
picture had nothing to do with the
picture although I had to do with the
documentary this this person said your
documentary and your books have
absolutely changed my life I just want
to say thank you so much for what you do
I just want you to know that I really
appreciate it and the first thing I was
said after that said hey where can I get
that bag that's in your documentary whoa
and look I get it
we all flash on you in certain things
and if you truly need a new bag that
Malcolm fonti a bag could potentially be
a great bag but you can't have it I'm
sorry it's there's one left because
Malcolm font yeah he started this sort
of art project it was a five year
project where he made some very
deliberate goods in the late Oddie's in
early early 2010's early teens I don't
know what you would call that but I
think in 2013 he ended that project so
he stopped making bags he said okay my
five years are up and I'm done with that
so it was a very limited number of bags
that he made and put out there now so do
I have anything I could recommend
instead of that well maybe eventually
our friends over at clever travel
companion calm they make some really
interesting travel where I have not worn
I can't I can't recommend it personally
they're talking about recreating that
bag and if so will will let everyone
know on our email list or whatever but
until then if you really need a new bag
if you if you're a backpack kind of
person it sounds like the Menaul bag
worked out great for you and a lot of
like Jason's ook uh-huh he has the
Menaul bag I know a lot of our friends
like in this in this whole blogosphere
is podcast world friend podcasts podcast
I was gonna say that but then I was like
just don't don't try it
pods fear we've already wrote do you
read ourselves with rice okay
but no I I know a lot of people who use
it I see them posting on you know the
social medias and I feel the same way
about the bad guy absolutely but I
haven't posted it because I don't like
to brag about the things that I have
yeah yeah and again like the things that
I have it adds value to my life doesn't
mean it's gonna invite other people's
life and I had a lot of trepidation
going into this episode because I tend
not to recommend brands we don't
advertise for anyone and and these are
just things none of these brands are
paying us no and nor would we take their
money for them to you know put ads cuz
then we wouldn't have to talk about them
right right and I'd prefer to just talk
about them in a way that is genuine here
are the things that add value to my life
if I were to replace that bag right now
the few companies I would try until the
truffle clever travel companion calm
until they are able to reproduce that
bag I'm holding out for that by the way
I'm just gonna wait and see if muck
because this bag I have we've been on so
many tours with it it's it's hanging by
a thread in some places I've had dippers
replace I've had things resewn it is
I've really put it through the wringer
but um ever Lane I've already mentioned
but they make some really good bags a
friend Colin right who is the world
traveler he replaced his his uh NOC
lefante bag he hit with a Neverland bag
oh my goodness yeah Tom bin BiH in make
some great travel bags that a lot of
people have recommended and of course
mission workshop and Menaul we've
already recommended I really love the
folks at Mission workshop and and their
mission that they I mean it's just you
know it's it's there it's in our name
mission workshop yeah
they create very intentional goods and
all the same with them in all they they
create only a bag that's the only thing
they do is create those bags right guys
from New Zealand yeah a couple guys from
New Zealand they started with a
Kickstarter that was wildly popular so
you can definitely check those out and
then it's not
summertime so we tend to forget about
these things Ryan but our shorts I I do
wear shorts in the summer how do you - I
wear a something called a brand called
prana PR a in a and I think it's the
asanas short is what I wear and I'm just
going off the top of my head here and I
wear yoga pants around the house they're
like a pair of sweatpants basically my
company called for earth the number 4 -
rd8 I started I ordered a pair large of
4 or fours and I put them on and they're
just this like so tight around my quads
cuz I got these massive man quads and
then I was like how much weight he left
Sean at the at the gym all of it all of
it and then I returned them and got
extra larges and still like super tight
my quality the such a nice guy over
there like we're emailing back and forth
I'm like dude these are just not working
out can I just return these like I was
the owner oh yeah I don't want to
exchange him anymore he's like what's
wrong with them like my legs are just
too big for your pants yeah it was like
okay no worries they're so great for me
but my partner Rebecca she will often
take mine and wear them and that's she
has bigger legs and I did because she's
you know a former soccer player and
she's in really really really great
shape
and so yeah I think my my yoga pants
will they look back here on her but they
certainly fit her
yeah I I've I wear those around the
house I exercise in them at the house I
do all my stretching and yoga at the
house with those and then at I go to the
sauna several times a week and you and I
wear the same shirt same brand of tiles
yeah miles yeah my le s yeah that's
correct and they're based out of San
Francisco as well they make really
simple but also beautiful dude the deep
pockets and then it's got that little
like weird side pocket that goes like
around your waist kind of sort of I'm
probably not explaining that right foot
but it's got like this like imagine a
mitten for the people listening and like
that's what the pocket is like Lions
holding up his hand right now in the
shape of Michigan so you've got like the
pocket that goes down but then like if
you're if you if you got your hand
facing down and your thumb is pointing
off to the left there or
right however you have your hands Ryan
look this really awesome right now
there's a there's like a little like
side pocket that goes off the main pike
anyway no but they did that
intentionally because they were tired of
stuff falling out of their shorts they
were tired of not being able to like you
know fit whatever it is you need to fit
but like I've been able to think like
the craziest thing I've carried my
Kindle in my pocket before oh wow yeah
Wow yeah so the big pockets those shorts
are a bit baggy for me but I use them
for that I mean for me but I think they
fit you great and most feel they fit
great but my legs are so thin that
they're great for swimming and they're
great for going to the sauna
I literally born their shorts to a
wedding there you go like there they
look nice yeah yeah I think they do look
great you could totally get away if you
a very casual business meeting something
like that they do they look really great
and you can also run a marathon in them
as well I I wear a slightly slimmer
short with the with the Parana shorts
and then the last thing people often ask
me about where do you get your red
underwear because you've seen the
documentary and you know that when I'm
on the road the way I separate my dirty
and clean underwear is by having the one
pair of red underwear in fact Bex will
often look at me if I'm wearing the red
underwear I just say oh it's laundry day
isn't it because she knows that I'm down
to my last pair of underwear I think
it's important no I don't own nearly as
many clothes now but I still I own
enough clothes I don't have to do
laundry every day I do laundry once a
week typically and I own I own enough to
get me at least through the week but it
was absurd before right I could have
gone months not just a month not just
weeks but months without without doing
any laundry and of course when you do
that in fact I tried that back in the
days I went through a whole bunch of
laundry I would constantly keep wearing
clothes well you then you have a
mountain of laundry you have to do and
then you start whittling it down you're
like I don't want to wear this I don't
want to wear this I don't want to wear
this if you ever get that thought in
your mind like I don't really want to
wear this today she's probably doing it
yeah you should probably find someone
else who can who can use that thing I
hate I hated that when I had so many
clothes like three weeks a month worth
of clothes whatever it was and then I
went to go do laundry and it was just
like piles and piles and piles
laundry yeah she's like so much easier
to have like a week's worth of clothes
I'm like okay I have to do laundry
there's like it forces you to do laundry
every week instead of stressing you have
to fold your clothes cuz well I mean I
guess sometimes I'll just like live out
a little laundry the clean laundry been
something I would never ever do that I
know let's see a couple other things
real quick here a couple other brands
that I found oh I didn't even give the
brand my underwear just the best
underwear I've ever had is just jockey
its jockey I wear the Midway brief
they're really like their long-wear
actually you might like the XO XO fishy
oh I don't know XO XO fish o ex-officio
ex-officio maybe that's how you
pronounce it but anyway I love a man
they are I like because I was
I swear Haynes uh-huh and I just they're
not very durable right and they're not
that super comfortable and they don't
look that great lay so yeah I just like
one through different a few different
pair like I thinks I tried on sacs which
those are quite si xx like those are
okay but the ex-officio like for me like
fit me way better and they're super
durable and yeah like they're awesome I
love them a lot yeah so so my add a lot
of value my underwear are I just prefer
really long underwear and I found these
yeah pretty much
and so what else Oh real quick I I wore
some flip-flops
Havana's I think they're called or the
flip-flops I wear they're super
comfortable I again I wear those to the
sauna and I mean I wouldn't wear because
it's not great for your posture I
wouldn't wear flip-flops walking around
town the pair of flip-flops I have I got
because of the twenty20 rule oh nice in
Australia so 2020 round they armed is
the just in case rule
yeah the just in case was so like I did
not because I packed my Xero shoes and I
packed some sneakers or my boots for
Australia and I had a pair of flip-flops
what was actually it was Mariah's
flip-flops that I would use and then I
want to take her flip-flops yeah even
though it was like fall here and I think
she would wear them but I was just
thinking to myself the 20/20 room like I
don't really think I need it I am
bringing on just in case but it turned
out when we're in Austria I was like
d I really wish I had some flip-flops
for the beach and stuff cuz like the
zero shoes are great except for when
you're walking in the sand right because
like they have a strap on the back which
is great for walking yeah so the sand
yeah we'll get into in the zero shoe my
feet will sweat it forms a little clumps
on the zero shoe which dried I mean it's
really really bad and then when you get
in the water because they are attached
to your feet like the water will grab
the 0sh right and pull it off your foot
and it breaks like that's how I will
usually pull the string through it was
like from having them in water so right
when we were like in Gold Coast and it's
like surfer town there it's like god I
really wish I had some flip-flops I
should have brought those flip-flops but
we have we went and found a pair of
flip-flops for less than 20 bucks right
20 Australian dollars in less than 20
minutes right yeah so it was Adam ever
since yeah I don't know the brain of
them but yeah I still use them yeah yeah
and actually other corner store brands
now yeah Mariah is the ones that I use
of hers ah those broke so now she shares
though probably a while with you to you
you you two are able to share stuff like
that
let's see I wear some water so speaking
of water shoes I actually wear a pair of
water shoes the company is going from
water yeah yeah it's the the the company
is called the Emperor's New Clothes
no it's I think it's called shock WA and
I wouldn't wear I I don't really need
these and except here in Montana we go
to these hot spring hot springs all the
time and I was constantly hurting my
feet like I went to the boiling River
and messed my foot up I went to Jerry
Johnson mess my foot and like you know
I'm just really clumsy and I I don't
have great balance and so they and my
feet aren't even that tinder but like I
would mess them up and so I I Ryan you
brought up the tender foot I'm thinking
maybe if you go to Jerry Johnson or most
people don't know is that on tour I'm
always complaining about how bad my feet
hurt because we walked so much and Josh
calls me Ryan
Tenderfoot nicodemus yes my feet don't
hurt when I go to Jerry Johnson and
stuff
well I for whatever reason like I know I
know you said it's slipping and yeah
right and so these water shoes have have
probably literally saved my life in at
least one occasion because I fall a lot
and I've hurt myself
I mean I've strained muscles that Jerry
jauntily it's just not good but with
these with the water shoes on it's been
it's been outstanding also you have the
Xero shoes I those didn't work as well
for me but uh in the summer I will wear
to the gym I'll wear a pair of limbs le
M s and our friend just an archer who
runs the posture guy.com was a guy who
recommended those to me and got a lot of
value from those so it's like zero shoe
in terms of it feels like you're walking
barefoot but it's a full sort of sneaker
what you called a barefoot step what did
you know I think it was a zero step me
seriously anyway yeah or a zero instead
I don't know and the last thing that I
have in the winters for snow as I have
some winter boots from echo and although
whenever those go bad I'm gonna replace
them with the boots I recommend it to
you recently because I know you've
you've fallen several times this this
winter are the what what Becca wears on
what ello wears as well as a company
called extra-tough and it's spelled
really funny I think it's XT or a tu f
all one word but these are what the
Alaskan fishermen wear in the yeah and
it's lift these up these are the ugliest
boots of that they are not the most
aesthetically pleasing boots but I'll
tell you me I've seen I seen backs like
jog on ice before without any properties
of yeah and and well I think they lend
themselves to a simpler wardrobe as well
because they are fairly simple
themselves but they when you talk about
function over-over form this is true
function and they are pretty simple and
that they work in rain in in mud and
snow they're just great all-around boots
I have not worn a pair of myself but
Ella and Becks both love
there's so next time I need I need some
winter or rough yeah rough rather rough
weather boots rice weather boots you
heard it here folks and this next clip
is from our overwhelm episode it was
episode number 68 we talked about being
overwhelmed and how to deal with that
throughout the episode here's a question
and an answer from episode 68 from the
beginning of 2016 I started to
experience severe depressive episodes
and was ultimately diagnosed with
treatment resistant major depressive
daughter order once I started my fourth
and fifth medication ultimately I had to
take it either long absence from school
and now I'm still in recovery although I
recognize now that I have a serious real
mental health disorder that I have to
live with I still can't come to grasp
the term grasp the term that my life has
been only taken as a type-a personality
I am made unable to process these
changes allow myself to forgive myself
and move on from what appears to me to
be like a failure leaving school
abruptly well temporarily well at while
is temporary
it stripped my confidence and
self-esteem and has punished me deeper
into depression my question for you guys
is do you guys have any advice for me on
dealing with these unique circumstances
how do you guys deal with setback how do
you view failure and how do you process
failure do you believe it is possible to
have a functional meaningful life even
if you suffer from mental illness like
severe depression or anxiety
maile we are first off grateful that
we're able to add value to your life but
you know yes it is absolutely possible
to live a meaningful life when dealing
with a mental illness so I just want to
reassure you that um I thought of this
parable last night Josh I don't I don't
know if you will enjoy this because I
know you hate animals animals and onions
Josh despises
but you're like giraffes there was a big
purple tongue pretty good you know
recently they found out there are four
different species of giraffes like it's
not just one specific giraffe anyway no
but so I always your ass makes you stick
out her tongue well no cause like no one
knows right and so III told her that it
goes and so like we'll be somewhere I
would like be it like some ones house
you know and they're all kids are
together playing and and I'll say hell
what sounds giraffe make it shows go to
look over so just go and other parents
like is that I guess it is the sound it
sounds like on an elephant that is lost
it's like voice box or something alright
well here's here's here's the parable I
have for you my late you know I want you
to imagine like a straight draw a
straight dog that you find on the side
of the road it's been hit by a car and
it's wounded obviously and as you
approach the dog kind of snarls a little
bit out of fear and tries to keep his
distance but eventually she realizes you
are her only hope for survival and she
lets you pick her up and at first
embrace you know she looks at you with
those there's big puppy-dog eyes funny
how adult dogs can still have like
puppy-dog eyes sometimes and you know
gives you a nice slobbery lick on your
face and after you saved this dog's life
with the help of the vet you bring her
home and she is as happy as can be and
it seems great but then you know the
first time you invite company over she
gets scared and yet pees on the carpet
and runs and hides and you think to
yourself oh well you know this is you
know I gotta acclimate her to company I
gotta acclimate her to my friends and
family so you think yeah eventually
she'll warm up to others but you know
what it never happens and time and time
again the dog gets scared it hides it
pees on the carpet when anyone else
comes around but you but you and this
dog have a very very good relationship
so so what do you do like do you start
to despise that dog you start to hate
that dog do you do you get rid of that
dog for its you know repeated failures
to acclimate towards other people
of course not like you're going to
you're going to love that dog so I guess
here's my point is we all fail we will
all fall down at some point but after we
fall isn't it wonderful when a kind
person reaches out their hand to help us
get back up on our feet so you know I
think my biggest piece of advice for
Miley here is you have got to find
people who are going to be there to
extend a hand and you have to avoid the
relationships with those who don't at
the end of the day the people who judge
us for failing who who pass up the
opportunity to help us get back up on
our feet they don't deserve to be in our
lives so you know I mean I know we
preach community all the time Josh but I
think a Miley situation like this is
this is probably this is what I would
see as her like number one focus is
having people around her that do care
for her that are going to are gonna
offer a hand when she falls down we all
fail every single one of us in fact the
one thing I do want to recommend for
Miley here is a TEDx talk by a gentleman
named I'm gonna really butcher this name
I think it's a gia Young okay okay all
right
I think I actually that's probably
really close yeah so it is thank you it
is it is this gentleman who I'm just
gonna give you the gist cuz I don't want
to like do any spoiler alerts um and
it's like a 20 minute long or 15 minute
long TED talk but he basically comes to
a point his life where he is so tired of
being scared of failing that he goes out
of his way to get comfortable with it so
he literally goes out and practices
failing and it's a great story and we
saw this guy talk at the world
domination summit that Chris Gayle about
puts on yeah
and it was it was by far I think we've
been to like three maybe four world
domination summit the best talk I've
seen out of all out of all is
so I mean for me it just it really
motivated me so we'll put that in the
show notes but yeah I would I would
recommend watching that also to kind of
help you get over your feeling there I
was thinking of the the first scene of
house of cards when you're going through
your parable but apparently it ended
differently yeah yeah for those who
don't like animals yeah sorry for that
parable but I know there's I know we got
a lot of readers who who love their pets
I'm just I'm just thinking of Frank
Underwood in that in that first scene
anyway so first off obviously my Liam
I'm not a doctor I don't play one on the
podcast or the internet and so I'm gonna
I'll give you some advice as if I were
in your situation okay and so first of
you talked about how you're a highly
ambitious med student there's a line
from our book everything that remains
the the you reminded me of with with
your question it is not ambition that
sets a man apart it is the distance he
is prepared to go and I think I think
that's true we can all be ambitious with
respect to something but they're always
going to be obstacles in the way as well
Bex is reading a book by Ryan holiday
right now called the obstacle is the way
and I think we need to keep that in mind
like there will be obstacles but we have
to we have to go over we have to go over
them and and for you this depression is
an obstacle or what you're calling a a
mental illness is that the book that is
best part of the she's part of the book
club right yeah yeah it's with Jess
Williams and Mariah's yeah is that the
book right yeah it's funny because I was
telling this parable to Mariah I was
like does this make sense like is this
art and she recommended that book as
well so but yeah it really isn't the the
the ambition it's the distance you're
prepared to go and there will always be
obstacles in our way and you mentioned
you know how sometimes we fail sometimes
we succeed and I remember when we used
to do interviews we would interview
people they say what's your great like
what's your biggest weakness or or tell
me about a time you failed and in the
problem with that is it's not by an area
like that most of our forfeit our
failures are
also successes and most of our successes
are peppered with failures and once we
realize that that there are going to be
many miniature failures along the way
there will be many miniature successes
along the way it's all an amalgamation
of both you're not going to learn you
know it's like when I play basketball
right if I'm shooting free-throws I'm
not gonna make 100 percent of them so if
I if I shoot 10 and I make 8 that means
I failed twice
sometimes I'll fail 5 times sometimes I
won't fail at all and it's really up to
us to say okay that isn't a failure it's
just it's just something I missed and
the overall I can determine whether or
not is a success or a failure
but for Miley specifically I think of
the the Tony Robbins
quote he says we don't get depressed we
do depressed and I think that's true
most of the time even when we are in a
depressed state we can often change that
by changing our our state we're changing
our physiology first so the first thing
we want to try to do is change our
physiology many depressed people don't
exercise and so finding ways to get
rigorous exercise in there are a lot of
studies that show that people who are
depressed when they implement rigorous
exercise for just a couple weeks have
found in their their levels of happiness
and contentment raised significantly
it's a forty-five minutes a day every
day for two weeks and you'll notice a
significant change but you'll notice the
change even before that you put if you
go look in the mirror put a big smile on
your face jump up and down for 10
seconds and silly as that sounds you do
it by yourself no one's gonna laugh at
you you're going to feel a change in
your physical state the I always hear
this thing about faking a smile like oh
that person was faking the smile is
actually not something you can fake a
smile is a smile right it may not be
genuine but it is a real smile and it's
going to change your state a little bit
and even if it's not a genuine smile
that person is trying yes why would you
ever knock someone right for fakes
unless unless it's like a patronizing
yeah I've heard me a page from chorus
yeah but I guess someone's like trying
to be in a good mood and like you can
tell they're they're forcing a smile yes
even though it's not a fake smile to
patronising smile and so so yes you want
to you want to change your physiology
and then
after that you want to change your
language you're using some language here
that I I wouldn't use especially illness
and I get doctors use this but it though
they'll use the term illness but to me
that is a limiting belief right and we
all have we all have obstacles in our
way and so maybe instead of saying
illness say have some mental obstacles
it's okay to say that yeah it's okay to
reframe it because once you reframe it
the language that you use you'll be able
to start focusing on what you can do as
opposed to what you can't do so the
language you use will then lead to the
focus if you change your body language
or you change your physiology you change
the language you're using the frame
whatever this challenge or obstacle is
and then you're going to change what
you're focused on because if you focus
on the right things what you can change
then you'll start changing them if you
focus on things you can't change
you'll feel overwhelmed you'll feel
despair and then of course you'll start
to feel hopeless longer-term moving on
here is another question and answer from
our values episode certainly one of my
favorite episodes of the year was
episode number 69 where we really get
into the different types of values and
try to help people understand what their
values are so they can live a more
meaningful life I was really unhappy
about seven years and so as I had
unhappy marriage unhappy life at last
spring me my wife stole pretty much
everything we had and we took a six-week
trip across the United States with our
two toddlers and now I live back in
Vermont I have a completely different
job and I've really embraced the
minimalism point of view my question for
you today is about values in the past
years that you've been a minimalist and
identified as that have you found that
your values have changed and how do you
how do you deal with that and what's the
best way to deal with that so Andrews
story reminds me of a story that I was
telling on Facebook live the other day
Ryan we were having one of our Mondays
with the minimalist sessions we're
answering four questions and to me I had
this friend he
he does canning or what their their jars
but we call it canning but their mason
jars and I want to call it mason jarring
he does jarring with like foods food
stuffs right I love food and so but if
you have a whole basement full of these
jars before you put anything in them you
have to boil water and sanitize these
things so they're clean but if you boil
the water and sanitize these these jars
and then put them back on the shelf for
a month they're not ready a month from
now right and it to me that was the
perfect metaphor for minimalism because
Andrews talking about how they sold all
their stuff and then that would have
been the first step getting rid of the
clutter is the first step but it's not
the end result you then have to figure
out what to fill it with once you've
sanitized your life so to speak you have
to figure out the fill with and and then
he filled it with some travel he and his
two toddlers and his wife went took that
six-week trip and and man he's found
more happiness in his life and now that
he's back in back in Vermont and he has
a different job he say okay have my
values change and he's asking us guys
did your values change once you embraced
minimalism and I think for me the short
answer is no but my priorities changed
so not my values but my priorities and
also my beliefs change I think of my
beliefs as the pathway to get to the
values and and that's why Ryan and I
have radically different beliefs about
religion and also about politics but we
have similar values we get to the same
place via different pathways and I've
recently been writing about this and
thinking more about it as not just a
like a road pathway but more like a
waterway and the water sometimes gets
redirected as your beliefs change if
something just comes and plugs up the
dam then all of a sudden your water is
gonna move in a different place your
belief is going to change you're still
headed towards your values most likely
but your values rarely changed it tend
to solidify and for me my values with
minimalism once I got the excess out of
the way I was able to see clearer and
and more clearly identify what my values
are and
put into practice and writing them down
and then trying to live that life in
accordance with with my values and now
whenever I feel discontented I I
realized it's easier for me to determine
why because I'm just not living up to my
values and so because it's easier for me
to determine why it's also easier for me
to to fix it maybe not easier it's
simpler for me to fix it because I'm
able to identify what the problem is and
that's the first step in in offering any
sort of solution yeah no I totally agree
man yeah my values again the short
answer is no my values did not change
once I went down this this path of
minimalism and introducing this
philosophy into my life what it helped
me do is be honest with myself I'd help
me to like look in the mirror and really
get clear on like a what my priorities
are and to act on on those priorities so
no I I don't think I don't think my
body's changed but but yes certainly I
just have a much clearer picture now of
what I need to focus on I was just
thinking about this me like I didn't
know what my values were really I mean I
probably could have rattled off some
things yet that I would have said or a
valueless oh well my health is important
obviously right right but I was 80
pounds heavier and I was eating fast
food and and loaves of bread and yeah
and I'm like oh my relationships are
important but my mom lived a half hour
away and I you know might have seen her
like six or seven times a year yeah
and it's I mean I didn't really do a
good job of fostering relationships yeah
lip service priority as we call it
here's a clip from our episode with Rob
Bell we were in Los Angeles together and
at the Belasco theater downtown Los
Angeles and man I always enjoy just
listening to Rob talk because I learned
so much from him and in his regular
podcast which is called the Rob cast but
then talking with him in person I always
feel like I learned something I hope you
do too hi my name is Sam hey Sam Ventura
California
welcome I'm super nervous so thank you I
just wanted to start off by you guys
have helped shape my life and like the
past year dramatically and the biggest
thing that I've taken away
letting go of toxic people and I think
I've done an incredible job I'm down to
like three friends and I'm so happy I've
never been happier with genuine people
in my life so my question is I have a
very toxic person in my life and they
have an addiction and my question is is
how do you divorce somebody when they're
your parent and they're bringing a toxic
environment not only to your life but to
it's causing me to have a toxic
relationship slightly with my husband or
you know it brings up some commotion or
it's holding me back from being a better
sister or even being a the best daughter
that I can be to them and I'm having a
really really hard time with pulling
myself away from somebody who's so toxic
so how do you walk away from somebody
who will always love but you don't want
to be a part of that kind of environment
I will start with a pithy answer then
I'll try to unpack it a little bit the
thing that I've learned over the years
is that victims become victimizers and
and so I had people in my life for sure
that played the victim role repeatedly
and and dragged me down with them and so
we all hear this sort of platitudes of
you are that the five people you
surround yourself with your five closest
friends and and that ends up being true
and so I think one way for you to to
remove yourself from that it's that not
run away from that but to run towards
something else and find relationships
and people who are going to be
supportive people with similar values
and
and I think that ultimately when you're
when you're dealing with someone who
you've been so close to for a really
long time you you can't help someone
that doesn't want help I guess my
biggest fear is walking away and I guess
it's like how much do I give of myself
to try and help them when I get in back
of my mind I also know too that they can
only help themselves yes are you do you
think this person will change on their
own
I want to believe but I can't answer
that only they can well well then I'll
give you my my short answer it's one
that you've heard before probably you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you and
I think you have to surround yourself
with some supportive relationships and
model you have to model the behavior
that you want to see from from that
parent and in doing so either great hope
is that they will follow I mean the nice
thing is a lot of people in my life from
from my 20s they thought I was crazy and
I had to walk away from that but
eventually when I modeled the behaviors
that I wanted to see and myself they
ended up following man um I'm so sorry
to hear about your situation night no no
it's not I just I've been there and yeah
it does
man I hate hate to like air out all my
dirty laundry but like I have I have a
relative I'll just say that I have a
relative in prison right now who is
because of drugs and they were in prison
they got out I was helping them as much
as I could
brought them out to my home gave them
some money to you know start a new life
with and they ended up back in prison
again and when they did they called me
up and they're like hey man can you give
me money for a lawyer
and I'm like no like I'm sorry but I
can't I'm not willing to do that like
I'm willing to write you I'm willing to
talk to you I'm willing to support you
whenever you won but supporting you with
in a monetary fashion like that's just
in my opinion enabling you and I've
already done that and it hasn't done
anything for you and that's not any
knock against you I just know that until
you really really want to change no
matter how much money I give you or
stuff I whatever it is until you really
want to change like nothing is actually
gonna change in your life so I guess
what I'm saying is is um even other
family members like they still they
still don't get what I'm doing they said
you know if I see them they always got
to make some kind of smart nice orange
shoelaces minimalist like I can't
believe you have colored shoelaces and
you know is that shirt adding value to
your life I mean just constantly take a
drink and you know at the end of the day
like those family members I do love them
so much but I will distance myself and
some of them have to completely come
around and my relative who's in prison
right now like I we we still have a good
relationship there is nothing I can do
to change the change them that they're
going to have to change themselves but I
will still be there for them
I would say don't I don't think you have
to walk them I mean maybe you do I don't
know this is just my two cents I would
say you don't you maybe you don't have
to walk completely away from from this
relationship as much as distance
yourself as much as possible still show
them that you care and love them and
support them in every way that you can
but don't ever so
or it's someone for the sake or does my
pity answer I got it don't go out of
your way to support someone and forsake
your own meaningful life some people you
have to love from a distance and that
means you're going to have to have a
funeral for the parents and the
relationship you wish you had and that
will involve grieving because they
haven't been able to come with you so
the real question to ask is how much can
you engage with somebody without losing
yourself and if you find that two hours
of engagement takes you two weeks to
flush the toxins out or you and your
husband have to do like a week of am I
crazy because they lobbed all that stuff
like a Katy Perry melody it got stuck in
the front of your head how many of you
have somebody in your life who they know
how to say something that gets looped in
your frontal cortex and then it just
plays on repeat so here's the thing you
don't have to be around that and and the
great heartache
it's literally thousands of year olds
old is what happens when you find
yourself at odds with your own tribe
maybe even the people who brought you
into the world because your path has not
continued on alongside their path and so
a second you asked your question I was
oh grieving its grieving think about it
like I am grieving what I wish I had and
then you have to continue on your path
and maybe it means loving people from a
distance here's something from our
nostalgia episode episode number 91 of
the podcast we talked about letting go
of nostalgia and how nostalgia might be
a little bit dangerous here's a question
and answer
from that episode my question is about
sentimental objects to try to make a
long story short I met my husband in a
bar in Georgia when I was 21 I was
living in Manhattan I was just down
there visiting a friend and we really
hit it off obviously I went back to
Manhattan we were trying to plan he come
visit me but he was in the army and he
got sent to Iraq and he said will you
write me letters and of course I did and
the whole time he was there in the
invasion we wrote letters back and forth
and I remember what moons my apartment
building and how excited I would get
just so you know open up my mailbox and
see a letter from him and we really fell
in love to those letters even married
for 10 years we have three year old twin
boys and I just know that those letters
are a sentimental object I will never be
able to get rid of like scanning them
just doesn't tell the whole story of
having been from you know Iraq and
Manhattan and back but I also know this
opens us up to like the rabbit hole of
wanting to keep you know that the baby
clothes my sons came in you know came
home and like one was in the NICU and he
was so tiny and he's strapping healthy
boy and like I have that in my dresser
drawer the clothes he came home in and
then of course it opens up t know
letters to other people and starting to
feel guilty and I guess my question is
um do you make room for sentimental
objects that matter a great deal and if
so how do you kind of stop the flood of
letting that put me hit everything else
in your house that you attach value to
so Ryan do you make room for for
sentimental item man I mean I have
sentimental items um I tried to avoid
holding on a centum on mental items as
much as possible God she's already kind
of went down the rabbit hole with the
letters yeah so now she's like I think
her question really is is like okay I've
got these letters
I'm not asking how I get rid of these
letters I'm not willing to get rid of
these letters they had a lot of value to
my life which is great and then she's
asking well now that we've got a kid and
I know that I'm gonna want to hang on to
stuff like how do I keep it from from
overflowing so you know I guess the
first question if I
Susan I would ask myself you know how
much room do I have for these things
yeah what's what's the real cost right
of owning these things because right the
there's no cost right now of of the the
the baby clothes are already paid for I
said there's right the there's no
monetary cost or for purchasing those
things at this point that's a sunk cost
right but there are other costs involved
with that yeah your the cost of the of
space yeah
the cost of time it takes to organize
these things to take care of these
things the the cost of well maybe if it
does get out of hand the cost of new
storage space so it could turn into a
monetary cost but it's quite often we I
mean I have a friend back in Cincinnati
we used to work with and I remember he
and his family like they bought a bigger
house just because they didn't have
enough space for their stuff and and
they were like really stressed that as
opposed to letting go of the stuff that
they were able to justify having a
larger mortgage being tied to more debt
just because they needed more space for
the stuff which by the way he even
acknowledged to me he goes I don't use
most of this but like I just feel like
we have to hang on to it and and we just
need more space and I'm okay with I'm
not telling everyone that I should live
in a tiny house course not we don't live
in tiny houses in fact the guy from
Nightline who was out at our and our
houses yesterday you know our house is
maybe 1,200 square feet Beck's and I and
it seems a lot more open than that but
it's not it's not a tiny house by any
stretch but it's what's appropriate for
us and we don't have access storage or
anything I mean we've got plenty of
extra space that we don't fill up but I
don't feel compelled to fill every
corner is really the point right and so
she used the word Ryan that that I tried
to avoid with my stuff she said it has
so much meaning or the meaning we
attached to it and and I think that's an
important she's actually admitting that
like the things have only as much
meaning as you give them right and her
letters that were written
I understand they mean something to her
and I'm not judging that at all no but
they literally mean nothing to me
but they could mean something to me if
you love it if I allowed them to yeah
and so yeah the thing I always think
about is when something's too precious I
try to let it go mm-hmm and be just
because when something becomes so
precious I become attached to it in an
unhealthy way and so the thing that I
would ask is why am i giving so much
meaning to these things because the
things themselves whether it's the
letter or the baby clothes or whatever
those things don't necessarily have
intrinsic meaning they have only the
meaning we've placed on it and that's
not in and of itself unhealthy what it
is it gets unhealthy when we give it too
much meaning too much significance too
much importance I couldn't live without
blank right my life would be terrible
without blank because the truth is no it
wouldn't right
everything would be okay without those
then the question that becomes how do
these improve my life how do they all
mint my experience of life and maybe
just maybe there's something she could
do with these sentimental items that
enhance her life as opposed to because
right now the you talked about having
these additional calls the biggest
additional call she's experiencing right
now is the weight they have on her mind
yeah they're occupying the real space
the space in her mind she's worrying
about these things
she is obsessing over these things
enough to call into a couple of random
guys from Dayton Ohio that she doesn't
know so that so that we can try to help
her with it so it's it's become enough
of an issue that she's worrying and it's
occupying space in her brain so how does
one find the balance between holding on
to everything and incinerating
everything so where's the where's the
balance between that and that that's a
good question because it doesn't and
that's gonna be different for everyone
too right yeah and often we think it's
by an area right like I have to either
hold on to it or I have to incinerate it
right and the truth is well maybe
there's something else you can do with
it with those letters could you turn it
into a really great art project
collage or yeah or a huge frame that you
have in your bedroom that is filled with
your your favorite selection of these
letters and by the way I do recommend
even if you're not gonna just scan them
I do recommend scanning them because
you're gonna it's gonna it's gonna
occupy less space in your mind because
you're not worrying about losing those
letters anymore if you you and I Ryan we
did a scanning party people we won't
rehash the whole thing you see the
scanner we use and exactly what we do
with all our photos and stuff the
minimalists comm slash scanning will put
a link to that in the show notes as well
but have a scanning party and go through
those letters together and then find the
ones that evoke the most meaning and
emotion when you're going through them
and maybe you can turn in some sort of
art project whether you said it's a
collage it could be a scrapbook it could
be a digital picture frame that actually
it's a large and they make large digital
picture frames now that are eight and a
half by eleven yeah and you can cycle
through those letters on the digital
picture frame you can set the timer so
every 60 seconds it brings up a new
letter and if they're private letters
you can keep them in a private place
just in your bedroom somewhere and and
you can get more value from it that way
than them just sitting in a box a
shoebox in an attic or a basement yeah
no I totally agree
III think you know Susan it's I mean
we're not well we are just sharing our
recipes so anything we say it's just
that like it's our experience it's
alright what we would do yeah but Susan
you can you know you feel free to do
whatever you feel is best for you and
your family if I was you I would when it
comes to the baby clothes you know I
would right now put a limit on so for me
if it was myself my limit would be zero
I'm not gonna hang on to baby clothes
not me but I find this with Ella now
when she grows out of something I get
rid of it but Susan if you know if it's
if it's that important to you I would I
would posit that it's not as important
as you think it is but you know like I
said I don't want to sit here and tell
Susan what she should or shouldn't do if
she's looking for some type of
guidelines on how to find that balance
between holding out 2-0 baby clothes and
then holding on to everything I would
say like figure out what that limit is
right now first off how much space do
you have
to store baby clothes and if you do have
space then limit yourself to just that
space I mean you know holding on to up
hair baby shoes a onesie like if that's
what you want to do great but put those
put those rules into place now
so when you do find yourself with a heap
of baby clothes in a trash bag you're
not just gonna take that trash bag and
then put it in the closet and hold on to
everything like right now decide what is
your limit what do you have room for
what do you have time for I found with
Ella it's actually a good it's a good
time for me to teach her as well because
when she grows out of something she
knows that we go donate it and instead
of just saying we have to go donate this
we talk to her about why she's donating
it and when she goes to the donation
warehouse with us or to Goodwill and and
we're donating her old clothes
she says this is so other kids can wear
it because I can't wear it anymore she's
understanding that I didn't understand
that at age 4 right but she's
understanding that at age 4 so it
becomes this this teachable moment and
that that we wouldn't get otherwise if
we were just clinging to her to her
style oh that's a great point Suman is
like so Susan what do you want to teach
your kids through this process Oh like
so what lesson do you want them to get
out of this do you want them to you know
realize that memories are inside of us
and we don't have to have a bunch of
physical items to remind us of those
memories or you know do you want the
lesson to be hey it's okay to hoard
whatever you want to hoard and I know
Susan isn't a hoarder or turning into a
hoarder but but yes I would ask that
question to Susan is like what do you
want to teach your kids through this
process well here is a hot topic for the
end of the year and especially going
into the new year we've wasted a lot of
money this year right and quite often
the reason we waste money is because we
don't have a budget together so we did
an entire episode about budgeting it was
episode number 94 enjoy this clip from
that episode I have recently been
applying minimalism to my finances I've
actually created an excel an excel sheet
which I thoroughly enjoyed nerding out
too as I fill it out I however do not
realize how much money I was spending
unconsciously on eating out and random
other items that do not add value to my
life anyway
I'm wondering if you have any words of
wisdom to encourage patience with myself
and or how to speed along the process of
developing and adhering through a
realistic value-based budget so you know
I got excited when I heard the word
Excel spreadsheet Ryan know I've stopped
using X I'm so proud of her because I
cannot dude my um I'll say a relative
I'm not gonna call out the specific
relative yeah but they were visiting
within the last year and they were like
I don't know what to do
like I need a car and I gotta do this
blow I mean you know they're just laying
out all their financial woes and I'm
like do you have a budget and they're
like no I'm like okay I was like I'm not
going to coach you anymore
until you come back to me with a budget
they still have not put a budget
together yeah there are so many people
out there who know they need a budget
have not spent the time to do it that is
if you can't take the first step then
you're never gonna become debt-free yep
so Tara just congratulations on putting
the Excel spreadsheet together that is
an awesome first step and it's a hard
one because it makes you it makes you
look in the mirror and it makes you be
honest with yourself
oh it's scrutinizing to like so in a
weird way I'm budgeting right now with
my diet so it talked about doing the the
ketogenic diet early on at the beginning
of this episode and the app I'm using my
Fitness Pal it I budgets my calories
yeah so my daily objective is 2300
calories but I want to get over 70% of
that from fat and so I find I find that
like I'm budgeting in a different way
and it makes you scrutinize like oh my
god I did not know that a tablespoon of
balsamic vinegar had yeah one carbonate
or whatever and so I I just I'm sorry
I'm just having visions of me taking on
this diet and freaking out of it about a
tablespoon of balsamic vinegar oh yeah
your your toast I'm sorry and I mean
like bacon so I'm eating bacon now right
but bacon is cured with brown sugar so I
can't even really do much begging you
think of
bacon is a nice fatty thing that's gonna
help your fat it does but bacon is
always cured with brown sugar that's how
you make bacon now Josh did you know
that if you say beer can in an
Australian accent it sounds like bacon
in a Jamaican accent prove it we don't
have time keep going all right all right
anyway so I'm budgeting and my whole
point is that once you start
scrutinizing it down to the dollar level
or the calorie level or the
micronutrient level it it opens up this
whole world of you know there's this old
saying oh you can't you can't manage
what you don't measure and I don't know
that it's always true but I think that
it's it is so true for diet and
especially for budgeting your dollars
knowing where every dollar is going
throughout the month now an Excel
spreadsheet might be might be ideal for
for tiara but there's a really good app
out there and it's free by the way it's
called every dollar
oh yeah that's Dave Ramsey's oh yeah and
so I used the paper version of it a very
long time ago and that helped me the
whole envelope system that he uses
helped me but every dollar it's a free
app and I think that it may be the Excel
spreadsheet works great for you and
however you want to do it whatever tool
works best for you but take a look at
the different tools see if see if that
one might might help out now Ryan she
said how to help her with with patience
well she didn't realize how much money
she was spending now I would use the
word non-essentials hmm so how do you
get down to that how do you figure out
what's essential and non-essential yeah
so you and I did something called the
neat needwant like list but if I were to
rename that today because we did this a
few years ago the needwant like lists we
really identified the things that you
truly need the things that you wanted
that added value to your life and the
things that you just sort of liked like
yeah I like the satellite radio or
whatever how would you rename it
essential non-essential and junk and yes
you I like that essential essential we
should go back and edit that essay or we
can just we can write another one
eventually I've been writing bunch on
the website by the way you can subscribe
to all the essays for free over at the
minimal
komm via email that due to centralized
on the central and junk is that's
essentially what it is man like yeah was
that was that a pun it was upon his
essentially yeah and and so we were we
were helping someone recently declutter
their home we were doing it for a
reporter on BuzzFeed this BuzzFeed video
video that we did when we were out in
Los Angeles when we were out on tour and
helped her put things in the three piles
and now here's the thing we justify
everything this is essential absolutely
need it but the truth is we need far
fewer things and we think and so if I
were to look at my essentials my non
essentials and my junk most of the
things that I owned when I was 27 years
old and I was simplifying my life for
the first time the vast majority 90 plus
percent was junk it wasn't actually
adding real value to my life it was
there was some weird perceived value or
I was holding on to it just in case and
in most cases but I had to slash that
and so a hundred percent of your junk
has to go now that such a junk that you
have at home it's the new junk that we
bring into our lives and what I mean by
that it's not actually adding value to
your life it could be eating out at
Chuck E Cheese because that's where I go
and I want to eat out do they have a
gluten-free menu I don't know then you
are there chuck-e-cheeses in the Pacific
Northwest I just want to say your
childhood wasn't lit unless you spend
some time at chuck-e-cheeses don't ever
use that word around me again what
chucky cheese yeah most of the stuff
that we spend money on his junk meaning
it's not adding real value to our life
but then there are some things that are
non essentials but it's not junk it
non-essential means it adds value to our
life but it's not absolutely necessary
and I found a way when I was first
budgeting this sounds crazy I found a
way to cut a hundred percent that's the
temporary deprivation a hundred percent
of those non essentials they'll give us
some examples let's see here so so so a
lot of the bills that I was spending
money on at home internet cable TV
anything I was spending money at run
regularly music things that that weren't
absolutely essential to God life going
out to e yeah most of the going out to
he was junk but it was for them because
because the the need was eating right
right and so maybe going out to eat with
friends yes then I did get some value
from him or yeah I got some value
because I didn't have to prep everything
but I did start making meals at home
because eating is essential so let's
let's just talk about essentials real
quick the essentials are things like
having a roof over your head having
clothes on well I already owned enough
clothes I didn't have to buy any new
clothes I can go shopping in my own
closet and be completely contented by
that experience but I found a way to cut
down my essentials by 50% I moved into a
smaller apartment I reduced my
electricity and use the air conditioning
less frequently I mean there were things
where I'm like I'm going to really
squeeze every dollar that I have here
and I even reduce my essentials by 30%
now maybe maybe Tara you can't you can't
reduce your essentials by 50% but maybe
you can reduce it by 20% and you can get
rid of all of the non essentials right
now temporarily here's the cool thing
about that though once you become
debt-free you start bringing those non
essentials but they still add value to
your life these are things that truly
add value to life when you start
bringing them back in it feels so much
better because you know you're bringing
it back in deliberately and you feel so
much less guilty man yeah like that's
the other thing too it's like I was
there when I was you know deep in debt
but I'm gonna go out with a friend and
have a meal and I'd put it on my credit
card right and it was a good experience
with my friend and I did get value out
of it but like I would feel guilty like
ah Here I am just putting more debt on
to this debt card yeah and now the other
thing that I realized when I started
bringing some of those things back in in
my life like I started buying music
again and and and buying books and
instead of going to the library and I
found that many of the things I thought
were non essentials
we're actually junk and I say oh yeah
this adds value to my life no no no it's
actually junk and so you don't bring any
of the junk back into your life so slash
slash
you can find that essay it's the
minimalists comm slash want we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
one last question she had how do i how
do i speed up the process well I think
he just answered that right because I
guarantee right now yeah so yeah I was
gonna say it like if I if she was to lay
out her expenditures I guarantee you and
I could find an extra 10 an extra 20
bucks a month maybe an extra 100 or $200
a month right but there I mean if she
truly wants to speed up the process get
clear on what the essential stuff is the
non-essential stuff is and give it and
give up as much as you can to pry
temporarily deprive yourself yeah I mean
dude eating peanut butter and jelly and
ramen noodles is a horrible diet but
yeah you can do the healthy equivalent
to that there is a healthy equal
actually we should actually start coming
up with a healthy equivalent we should
get backs to do that at minimal wellness
she's the dietician yeah so what's the
cheapest healthiest way to eat because
that's one thing I hear a lot too well
it's too expensive to eat healthy nah
that's a total [ __ ] it's too
expensive to not eat hell yeah you know
what it's too expensive if I go down to
the Fresh Market right here in Missoula
and eat organic there it's way too
expensive I never buy like I go to the
farmers market right or I'll go to other
places where I know that they have
affordable organic stuff well what I'm
saying is too expensive to not eat
healthfully what I mean is it's gonna
cost you in the long run oh yeah oh yeah
it's good yes and so here's here's well
says she said how do I speed up the
process and how do I be patient I don't
want you to be patient I want you to be
upset about this I want you to feel the
pain be impatient about your debt that's
what I wrote down here be impatient with
that don't accept debt don't have
patience with your debt be so impatient
that you know you must make some sort of
shittim added that they're dead yeah I
definitely don't want you to be patient
and in fact I don't need to be so
impatient that you so the equation here
is simple Ryan you have to make more
money than you spend if you want to pay
off your debt well how do you do that
well first off you spend less you give
the best way to give yourself a pay
raise is to spend less money if you want
a dramatic pay raise spin
matically less money but on top of that
once you've done that you figure out how
to make more money now for me we didn't
have Eber and lift back in the day so I
delivered pizzas and I felt like an
idiot I was working in the corporate
world delivering pizzas but I was I'm
gonna make some more money somehow and
make a few hundred bucks more a week I'm
gonna how am I gonna allocate my time so
I can earn more income in the short term
it's not a long term plan but what is
your side hustle and and maybe that's
driving with lifts and and any extra
time you have you got an hour five hours
a week yeah like it's gonna that's an
extra hundred bucks a week yeah and so
instead of pacifying yourself find ways
to schedule in that side hustle that you
can make some short-term money to pay
off those debts yeah so I would like to
rephrase her question about being
patient I think what she's asking is is
how can she stay more focused and what
I'll say is focus on your daily tasks
like don't look at what you're gonna be
spending next week or the week after
like you if you have your budget and
after listening to this podcast I'm
assuming you have slashed even more of
your expenses stay focused on what you
need to do daily and then also do focus
on that end result focus on being
debt-free you have a light at the end of
the tunnel do you know how many people
don't even have that light to look
forward to so if you can a just take
your daily tasks your daily maybe your
daily focus is a better way of looking I
hate the word task yeah but you know
taking on a day-to-day basis one step at
a time one action at a time and then
stay focused on that end result that is
what is going to give you some some some
better focus and help you stay motivated
to get to that that light at the end of
the tunnel
and finally every year around this time
especially as January rolls around I
start to think of one of my best friends
in the world a guy named Stan Dukes and
it's hard to even talk about but man
about four years ago he passed away
really early he was in his late 30s and
it was shocking and totally changed my
perspective on life and so Ryan and I we
try to acknowledge him at least once a
year and and try to inspire other people
to live like Stan because even though he
was young when he died he lived a life
that was inspirational and I'm grateful
for the time that we had together here
is a clip from that episode and so
January 2014 is is when he died and I
remember getting the news and I was just
I was shocked we were just starting this
tour and it was our first city yeah was
our it was our very first city and so I
wrote an essay about it that the night I
got the news and we put it up on our
website we'll put a link to that in the
show notes I was hoping to read that and
then Ryan maybe you and I could have a
conversation about the life that the
Stan lived and and the lessons that we
got from from his life because his was a
a profound albeit too short life for
sure this this essay is called live like
Stan the traffic light hanging above our
car is a blur of red tears are burning
my eyes Ryan is seated in the passenger
seat next to me he too is teary-eyed
it's the eve of our big hundred city
book tour the Florida Sun has already
set behind the Tampa Bay nightfall is
upon us now by the time the traffic
light changes it's just a mess of wet
green a shapeless emerald cloud spilling
into the nighttime ether I received the
call a moment earlier the news a week
after Ryan avoided his own death which
we can talk about in a moment the week
after Ryan avoided his own death one of
my closest friends
Stanley Dukes is dead this isn't going
to be easy to right overwhelmed with
unanswerable questions I feel a canyon
of sorrow
I can't see past the tears he was only
36 years old so I'm compelled to pin a
thousand cliches life is too short every
day is a gift
you never know when you're going to go
so live your life to the fullest
while these truisms are apt the truth is
that Stan lived more in his three and a
half decades than most people could in a
hundred years
Stanley dukes was a Mozart of positive
living and so his attenuated life was
not in vain of course this doesn't erase
the pain but it makes it easier to
handle we met in the corporate world a
decade ago at first when I was a
regional manager Stan worked for me as a
store manager but he was so talented he
added so much value to so many lives
that I often felt as though I worked for
him although he managed dozens of
employees his genius was most pronounced
in his ability to inspire people who
were not self-motivated which if you
know anything about leading people is
sort of like convincing water to be less
wet but somehow he did it always
carrying with him a smile and his
positive mental attitude as a result he
was one of the most successful managers
in the entire company over time we
became close friends we shared similar
values and beliefs as well as tastes and
literature and movies and music I traded
him over OTT short stories for his
hilarious pseudonymous erotic fiction we
exchanged lines from Glengarry Glen Ross
characters and we both shared a healthy
obsession for John Mayer's music we
became so close that he is even the
first person to make a pearance in my
memoir everything that remains where he
pops his huge loveable head into the
very first page and here's a an excerpt
from from that book our identities are
shaped by the costumes we wear I am
seated in a cramped conference room
surrounded by ghosts and searched
shirtsleeves and pleaded true
there are 35 maybe 40 people here middle
managers a lot of us mostly Caucasian
mostly male all using apathy the group's
median complexion is that of an
agoraphobe and Microsoft Excel
spreadsheet is projected onto an
oversized canvas pulled from the ceiling
at the front of the room the canvas is
flimsy flimsy and cracked and is the
shade of off-white that suggests it's a
relic from a time when employees were
allowed to smoke indoors the rest of the
room is aggressively white the walls are
white the ceiling is white the people
are white as if all cut from the same
materials well everyone except Stan
seated at the back of the room
Cincinnati's population is 45% black but
Stan is part of our company's
single-digit percentage his comments
though rarely solicited by executives
are often dismissed with a nod and a
pained smile although he's the size of
an NFL linebacker stan is a paragon of
kindness but that doesn't stop me from
secretly hoping that one day he'll get
fed up with the patronizing grins and
make it his duty to reformat one of the
bosses fish-eyed faces of course Stan
would and now we're back to the the text
here back to the essay of course Stan
wouldn't have touched a hair on any of
their balding heads he was above that he
was above all the petty BS we get caught
up in everyday he was above living life
based on other people's standards his
standards were too high for that he had
character Stan contributed beyond
himself each year at Christmastime he
dressed up as Santa and handed out gifts
to our employees he spent many off hours
donating his time the soup kitchens and
Habitat for Humanity and last year he
founded a mentorship conference for
young men ages 13 to 18 Stan cared when
I decided to leave the corporate world
three years ago he didn't flinch instead
he was the first to join me we walked
away together
guided by solidarity and a kinship
that's impossible
able to manufacture before I moved to
Montana we met for coffee weekly our
visits yielded heartfelt advice on women
and life as well as arguments over which
John Mayer album was best he said it was
battle studies and I said it was heavier
things so I don't know if you agree or
disagree with other of those but I feel
that I'm right
everything about Stan reflected a
profound truth even his simple tweets
were steeped in profundity here's a
selection of some of his tweets that I
have here a man can't walk out of his
own story that one was like the most
painful for me Ryan later it was I think
it was his final tweet actually Wow
let's see secure your own mask before
assisting others and he lived that by
the way I mean he helped other people
first or he helped he helped other
people but he made sure his life was
together first and then helped other
people rather yeah next week was there's
a bright spot in every shadow next week
was it's the bitter and the sweet I know
the bitter and that allows me to
appreciate the sweet next tweet only
your actions can prove your worth they
tell people who you are and then the
other one here this one was was simple
but so true don't drown in conformity
and sandela didn't conform it's the
reason he decided to leave the corporate
world yeah with me let's finish this
essay here it's almost over
countless essays on this site were
inspired by my conversation with Stan
our final conversation was mimetic of
his life it was short but meaningful
three days before Thanksgiving I sent
him a message I said I don't have to
wait until Thursday to be thankful for
you I'm grateful you're in my life every
day to which he replied succinctly
thanks for that please know that I feel
the same Stan lived until he died he
truly lived every day not like most of
us who walk through life like it's some
kind of dress rehearsal worrying about
BS that doesn't matter nope
stan was alive one of the only people I
know who didn't take this life for
granted if there's a lesson to be
learned here it's that like Stan we're
all going to die but few of us will ever
be courageous enough to live as he did
honest well-rounded passionate positive
and constantly improving above all Stan
Dukes was good people a man I aspire to
live like that green blur overhead is my
signal to step on the gas to wipe the
tears and move forward perhaps you'll do
likewise
I know Stan would alright we've come to
the end of this episode and I think the
great way to finish it here would be to
let Andrew Bell play us out we were at a
live episode of the minimalist podcast
in Indianapolis and we invited our our
new friend Andrew bell who has one of
the best albums of 2017 is called dive
deep and that episode is number 93 and
he played this live version of the title
track from that album so let's finish
2017 with a live version of dive deep
from Andrew Bell I hope you enjoy it
we'll see you next year yo
[Music]
this is my
[Music]
that be
[Music]
you said that I wanna keep
[Music]
we get carried away
don't stop I've got nothing to tell them
come boy you wanna start well I don't
wanna stay about here on your ski but
you will let me go Ice Age is on this
theory always started a feeling started
inside away it was foggy
I sticking around in space
[Music]
you started that I wanna keep
we carried away I can understand it with
a dis V New York fellow with a GD my
future city laughs you gotta sit my
photograph
we started inside away
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
and on our we boarded when it has to be
honest and obvious time
[Music]
and then we're out of the world
[Music]
you're
[Music]
you son
we carried away
don't stop
[Music]
you
[Music]
that be
[Music]
thank you